So we just finished talking about the sign in flow. Now, we're going to talk
about a second concrete improvement of how to make the UX of your app
better. And that is with the checkout form. So if you have an application
that involves your users buying something from
you, then this step is really important.
>> Yeah, and this is actually a point where 70%
of users on average on the Internet. Drop off meaning that
there's 70% abandonment rate of shopping carts across the
web. That's a huge number. That means like three
out of ten people are actually making it through
this form. When they see this form the first
reaction that people have is they run away. So,
so how do you actually make this form better
since it's such a critical part of you actually
getting paid. We need to make it easier for users.
>> Yeah, exactly. So how would you improve this form?
So, would you add more steps, for example?
Instead of having a single page with all
this information about building information, shipping information, credit
card information. Would you break it out into multiple
steps? Or would you improve the visual layout
of this form. Would you add more spacing,
bigger fonts, and make it so that people
can more easily type information in this thing. Or,
my favorite, would you actually add more text boxes to this form. because, you
know, that's the one thing that people like to do is fill out more
information on tiny, tiny mobile screens. Or
would you rather just replace this form
entirely with a pre-canned solution, like check
out with Google, or with PayPal, or Amazon.